[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
nous nos offres nous sommes arrivés
[Musique]
tu es de mauvaise humeur d'autres
mauvaises humeurs patron de très
mauvaise humeur il paraît qu'il ya des
enfants qui ne veulent pas aller se
coucher le soir ils type l'heure ce
n'est pas gentil et cela me rendent très
mauvaise humeur première de tonnerre
c'est le pain mais oui nounours tu l'a
appelée eau ont vite mis le seul et
europe
pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom pom
la panique ma petite pépite à l'orage
approche ferme la fenêtre moi je vais
n'abriter dans la grange voisine
ouf j'ai eu peur
bonsoir les enfants au besoin nous
regardons ce que je fais bravo ça
réchauffe
mais bêta petit tabou dont tu peux tu
faire mais chaque freinage
c'est tellement beau j'étais me regarder
leur âge
je veux pas voir ça
je veux pas d'autre sera actée pour à
evian doit à l'eau vient m'aider à faire
le feu mais non on vient voir nounours
c'est tellement pas que tu n'auras plus
peur ok
c'est affreux c'est la fin du monde
pepita je te défends de rester à cette
faune à
l'orage n'entre pas ici mais faut pas
être inquiet comme ça nous je ne suis
pas le seul à être inquiets je lisais
pas n'est pas là et s'est caché elle a
peur juliette à julienne
à l'hommage au lit il faut pas avoir
peur
mais où et pubs par gecina
nounours qui va être content
pepita ce n'est pas sérieux
il s est passé il aurait pu s'arrêter un
peu plus longtemps c'était si amusant oh
merci il est 13 ème à peut-être passé
par ici mais il a tout à fait raison de
continuer son chemin et moi aussi je
dois continuer le bien le marchand de
sable
matteau
leur âge et pas assez et chacun retourne
à ses occupations
pepita il est l'heure que tu rentres te
coucher
au revoir charmante pepita montpetit
cornichons devenu gibier tard pousse toi
les femmes qui peu de place au revoir
hamida bon retour camarades que la nuit
vous apporte calme et tranquillité
[Musique]
oh
encore le chrono c'est fini à présent
nous pouvons partir tranquilles tant
mieux bonnut les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents n'oubliez pas de faire
votre toilette l'avez-vous bien le draw
allez vite vous coucher une fête de boer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]